-Well, I mentioned your kids.
I heard you recently took them
to Coney Island.
-Oh, I did.
-Did they have a great time?
-We had so much fun, you know.
They grew up in L.A.
They haven't spent
a lot of time in New York.
So I wanted them to have, like,
a real city experience.
I wanted them
to experience the subway...
-Wow.
-...which they, you know --
-That is a thing now
that is actually, like,
child endangerment.
-My kid thought it was
the coolest thing ever.
I have footage of my kid
literally just looking out
the window going...
-That's great.
-...I mean,
just thinking it's amazing.
-They should rebrand
the New York City Subway
as like,
"The New York City Subway --
Fun for 2 to 6."
[ Laughter ]
-But we had --
we had a lot of fun.
There's all these little
food stands there.
I don't know if you've seen it.
-Yeah, it's great.
-And so we stopped off
for some ribs,
as you do in Coney Island.
-Yeah.
-Plus, you were covered
in fake blood,
so you thought,
"Oh, the ribs will cover."
-No, that was a different time.
-That's a different day.
Okay, gotcha.
And I'm ordering, and this lady
is trying to put it together.
You know, she's like,
"I think -- Are you --"
But she's not
putting it together.
So she's doing the whole,
"Do you get --
Do you get that a lot?
That you look like that actress?
What's -- What's her...?
[Fingers snapping]
You know, who I'm talking about.
You know who
I'm talking about, right?
You get it all the time.
You look just like her.
You look just like --"
And then, eventually,
she puts it together,
and I'm just trying
to have a good time,
so I'm like, "Oh, God, yeah, no.
I get that all the time."
And she goes,
"Mm-hmm. You know what?
No, no.
You're skinnier than her."
-Oh, wow.
-Literally. Literally.
-Now, that's very interesting
because --
-I don't know
if that's a compliment.
-Yeah, that's the weird thing.
How do you take it?
-What is that?
-Yeah.
-I was happy
and then super upset.
-Yeah.
I guess -- You want --
You want real life to be the one
that gets the compliment.
-I don't know.
I need a real friend
to actually tell me
what that means.
-Yeah.
-Somebody who really loves me
and can actually
tell me something
that I might not want to hear.
-Well, you know, whenever
I want the real truth,
I go straight to the rib lady
at Coney Island.
[ Laughter ]
You grew up in South Africa.
You grew up around animals.
-Yeah.
-And my wife's family
had a pet goat.
You had a pet goat growing up.
-Oh, really? Yes.
-What was your pet goat's name?
-Bok.
-Bok?
-Is that an Afrikaans word?
-It's B-O-K.
And it means "goat."
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah. Very creative.
-Did you have a long list?
Did you whittle it down to Bok?
[ Laughter ]
Was Bok confused
when other people
were just calling
for their goat?
[ Laughter ]
Did you --
Now, here's the thing.
I had a long --
[ Laughter ]
So, our goat, Raisin...
Raisin, sadly,
recently passed away.
-Aww.
-He was fine.
-Wait a minute. Time-out.
[ Laughs ]
-No, but I didn't think
goats were good pets.
Did you think goats
were good pets?
-Oh, my gosh. They're amazing.
I was -- How old?
I was maybe like 8 --
between like 8 and 13.
They're super mischievous.
[mis-cheev-eus]
-Yeah.
-Would you say "mis-cheev-eus"
or "mischievous"?
-We could do either one.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I would have said
"mischievous."
-Mischievous.
They're very mischievous.
They would jump on your bed
and kind of --
They'd eat your clothes.
They eat everything.
-See, these -- It's interesting.
All the things that
you're framing as positives
would have been
the negatives for me.
-I don't know.
It was -- I don't know.
There was something sweet
about it.
Um, I mean, she would
just play with the fabric
and then maybe get a hole in it,
but nothing, like, crazy,
you know?
But they get into everything.
I mean, they would stand
on the counters with
their little feet up, and...
But they're super-loyal.
[ Laughter ]
Very loyal.
-Yeah.
-And they're very --
And they're really loving.
Hey! I'm actually sharing
something for real!
Like, this is not a joke.
[ Laughter ]
This is actually me
sharing a piece of my heart.
-Yeah, guys!
Let Charlize talk about
how loyal her [bleep] goat was,
assholes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm really sorry about this.
-I mean, seriously.
-I don't know
what's got into them.
-I didn't have any siblings!
-[ Laughs ]
And if you had, their names
would have been
Sister or Brother.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's really lovely to have you.
Charlize Theron, everybody.